when it comes to landing Hollywood's
most coveted roles even established
actors have to show a little hustle with
the knowledge that Ben Affleck will no
longer be reprising his role as a Caped
Crusader for director Matt Reeves as the
Batman an actor from DC's Man of Steel
has tossed his name into the running for
the gig well the next stand-alone Batman
movie was originally set to be written
by directed by and starvin Affleck the
two time Batman actor has instead
stepped back leaving the role wide open
since then fans have been buzzing about
which stars might step up and Don the
cape and cowl and Affleck stead the most
recent name to pop up in association
with the Batman has been Robert
Pattinson the British actor who broke
into the mainstream of circulatory
vampire Edward Cullen in the Twilight
film franchise though Pattinson has
since gone on to prove himself as a
capable dramatic actor with movies like
good time and the maps to the stars the
internet still reacted somewhat poorly
to rumors of his involvement in the
Batman the backlash gave other actors
plenty of opportunities to throw their
own hats into the ring one voice in the
anti Pattinson as Batman camp offered
their own alternative thoughts about who
should play the leads in reves upcoming
feature instead pointing to christopher
meloni who appeared as Colonel Nathan
Hardy in 2013's Man of Steel
Schmidt is not our enemy
thank you writing on Twitter and early
February user Emily Diaz made an
emphatic case for the longtime character
actor writing no no and a million times
no dude Robert Pattinson would make a
terrible Batman I think Chris Milani
would make an excellent Batman slash
Bruce Wayne milani who was most
recognizable from his lead as NYPD
detective Elliot Stabler and Loren order
Special Victims Unit quickly caught wind
of the fans desire to see him grab the
superhero torch from Affleck the actor
took to his own Twitter page to retweet
the post revealing that he would indeed
love to play the Batman as milani wrote
in his post
yo DC Comics so this is what the kids
call going viral pull the trigger I'm
ready I'm Batman
milania's the Caped Crusader is a fun
thing to think about and the actor is no
stranger to the world of comic books on
top of his role in Man of Steel the
actor has also appeared in the comic
book adaptations sin city a dame to kill
for based on the comic book series by
Frank Miller as well as a sci-fi TV
series happy based on a miniseries by
Grant Morrison
milania's enthusiasm is also a
refreshing change of pace from the last
few years of batfleck which saw the Argo
director seeming to become less and less
enthusiastic about the role now that
Affleck is moving out of Gotham City
plenty of new actors names have emerged
for consideration including English
actor Jack O'Connell stranger things
start a camonte gamma ray and
singer-songwriter Nick Jonas
when Reeves first signed on to direct
the Batman it was briefly rumoured that
the dawn of the Planet of the Apes
director wanted Jake Gyllenhaal in the
lead role a possibility that Gyllenhaal
later himself shot down Gyllenhaal
instead signed on with Marvel Studios to
play the villain in spider-man far from
home another actor who's been rumored to
be angling for the role as Mad Men star
Jon Hamm who was once said to be gunning
hard for the gig however it seems
unlikely that either he or Milani will
ultimately get the parts unfortunately
despite milania's enthusiasm it doesn't
seem likely that Reeves and company will
end up selecting him for the role one
limiting factor is milania's age with
his 57 years falling far outside the
late 20s to early 30s range that Warner
Brothers seems to be looking for it's
been reported that Reeves take on the
Batman will focus on a younger
of the Caped Crusader which stands in
contrast to a flex version of an older
grizzled more world-weary character
Milani would be a versatile actor but a
young man he is not despite all that
history tells us that nothing is set in
stone when it comes to the Batman so if
the producers of the movie decide on a
radically different approach Milani is
waiting in the wings to take the job and
if he doesn't get the lead role who
knows he might still end up in the movie
Donald Glover's campaign to play
spider-man didn't get him cast as a web
slinger but he did still end up in
spider-man homecoming maybe Milani could
get cast as a villain and put its
intensity to good use against whoever
ends up actually donning the cowl we'll
find out what happens when the Batman
hits theaters on June 25th 2021 check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]